this time round we're in the Ukrainian
capital Kiev the snack we're checking
out is a true Eastern European specialty
and hungry it's called pollen shinta in
the Ukraine these pancakes are called
Lindsay or blini
the other than anything good in another
it's an old Russian dish not a Soviet
one it was around in the days of the
Tsar's they ate there's with caviar one
favorite blini joint and Kiev is Blin
Clinton a play on the name of the former
US president it's located on a busy
street full of office buildings a lot of
office workers stop by during their
lunch breaks for a snack original
Ukrainian blini are made with way and
buckwheat flour that gives them a nutty
taste
the kiosk owner mrs. betty anna has her
hands full making the light airy
pancakes a repertoire has long since
gone beyond the classic variety with egg
pancetta and sour cream
boy we make different sorts of blini
with different feelings some are sweet
some are salty people eat both breakfast
and lunch here we did the via deuce
customers are spoiled for choice
ordinary box if we have 20 times and
we're always coming up with new
combinations here we have chicken ham
mushrooms cheese and mayonnaise
regulars can order customized cleaning
which I like a mix of meat and veggies
and one more reason to visit Ukraine